This episode is sponsored by MagellanTV,
a documentary streaming service, founded by
filmmakers. Journey to the Microcosmos viewers
will get a one-month free trial on MagellanTV
by clicking on the link in the description.
Let’s start today by agreeing on one
thing: this is weird. We’re looking at
a dark purplish screen with little bits of white
floating towards the top, as if they’re bubbles
rising to the top of a glass of grape soda.
But that’s not the weird part.
The weird part happens when those bubbles suddenly
move in concert away from the frothy edge,
dragged towards one corner of the screen and
then towards the other. The effect is cosmic,
like we’re watching a million stars get
flung towards each corner of the sky.
And it won’t make it any less weird to know that
we’re not looking at bubbles or
stars. We’re looking at bacteria.
A field of them shaped by an invisible
force they are innately built to respond to.
Every swing towards one direction and then
another is visual proof of this unseen thing.
So what is it? What is the force
that’s driving them to move this way?
Technically, it would not be wrong to say that
the answer is James, our master of microscopes.
When James first saw these bacteria, all he knew
is that they came from a sample taken from a
Portuguese beach. And on each slide, the bacteria
were swimming in a stark line. And usually,
it’s not that strange to find bacteria swimming
in a line, especially when you realize that those
lines fall along particular chemical gradients
that correspond with the bacteria’s own needs.
But what was weird to James is that the bacteria
seemed to be congregating entirely on one side
of the slide. Now at first, he thought that there
might be some kind of food source over there
that was drawing the bacteria towards that
edge. So when he disposed of the slide,
he moved on, not expecting to see it happen again.
But the next day, James took a drop of water
from his sample and added it to the slide. And
there it was, another line. Just like he had
seen the day before, but the line was sticking to one
side of the slide, almost as if they were being
pulled by some invisible string in that direction.
And that gave James an idea. He took out his phone
and opened up his compass app. Then he placed
the phone on the microscope stage to see what
direction the bacteria were swimming in. And he
found that the bacteria were all swimming north.
So if we’ve seen this line of bacteria that’s all
swimming north, what’s with the other things we’ve
been watching, where the bacteria look like
they’re being dragged in other directions?
Well, as soon as James realized that his bacteria
were swimming north, he decided to go and grab
some magnets to see if he could trick them into
thinking some other direction is north instead.
So he held the north end of the magnet close to
the slide, and the bacteria began to migrate,
drawn in the direction of the magnet.
And then, he rotated the magnet so
that the south end pointed closer,
driving the bacteria to swim away.
What James had found—what we are seeing
in action—are magnetotactic bacteria,
or bacteria whose movements are
controlled by the earth’s magnetic field.
Magnetotactic bacteria were first described in
1963 by an Italian scientist named Salvatore
Bellini, who found them living in freshwater.
And when he saw them move with the same singular
northward focus that ours have been exhibiting,
he considered the idea that they might have
some kind of internal compass within them. But
while Bellini wrote up his work, it was only
circulated as manuscripts to some of the
universities in Italy instead of being published
in a journal for more scientists to find. That meant
that the existence of these bacteria wasn’t widely
known when a decade later, a graduate student
named Richard P. Blakemore collected some more bacteria
from a pond in Massachusetts and witnessed that
northward microscopic migration for himself.
Blakemore coined the term “magnetotaxis” to
describe what they were doing. And as he dove
deeper into the bacteria to understand how they
moved this way, he realized that they did in fact
have their own internal compass.
Or rather, compass-es.
Within these bacteria are a set of organelles
called magnetosomes. The core of the magnetosome
is a magnetic crystal—either iron oxide or
iron sulfide—that’s made through a series
of processes that involve the cell taking in
iron from its surroundings and mineralizing it
within them. The crystal is then wrapped in
a membrane to create a single magnetosome.
But as we said, magnetotactic bacteria don’t just
have one magnetosome. They have a set of them,
usually around 10 to 20, arranged in a chain to
create a dipole that can respond to the magnetic
field that crosses the world around the bacteria.
Magnetotactic bacteria are found all around the
world, but their preference is to live
in areas with low levels of oxygen,
like deeper down towards the sediment and
away from the surface. And this preference
has potentially important consequences for the
direction that magnetotactic bacteria travel in.
All of the magnetotactic bacteria discoveries
we’ve described so far, including the bacteria
that we’ve been watching, travel north. However,
all of those bacteria share something else in
common besides their propensity towards the North
Pole: they all live in the northern hemisphere.
Meanwhile, scientists have found that
magnetotactic bacteria from
the Southern Hemisphere will actually
travel towards the South Pole.
This is probably due to the incline of our
planet’s geomagnetic field lines, which
mean that as a bacterium travels towards its
specified pole in its preferred hemisphere,
it also swims downwards in the water
towards the sediment it prefers.
If a magnetotactic bacterium from the Southern
Hemisphere was forced to navigate the magnetic
field of the northern hemisphere instead,
it would find itself swimming upwards,
reaching waters higher in oxygen and
far less comfortable for the bacterium.
At least, this is the hypothesis for why this
apparent polarity within the distribution of
bacteria exists. But as always, there are
exceptions—southern-seeking bacteria found
in the northern hemisphere, and other strange
behaviors that scientists are still deciphering.
There are many other mysteries to magnetotactic
bacteria, like what advantages magnetism
even gives them—whether it’s to find the right
habitat in the water, or to hunt down particular
nutrients, or a combination of different factors.
And the bacteria probably don’t know why they
move this way either. It is simply baked
into them, a crystal that draws them
into invisible tracks. They are mysterious and
enigmatic. You might even call them, magnetic.
Thanks for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to MagellanTV for sponsoring
this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
There are a lot of unseen worlds that surround
us, and while we tend to focus on the ones we
can fit under the microscope, the James Webb Space
Telescope is out there studying the atmospheres of
exoplanets, and searching for the building blocks of
life elsewhere in the universe. And you can learn
even more about that by watching Planet Hunting
With The James Webb Space Telescope on MagellanTV.
MagellanTV is a documentary streaming
service, founded by filmmakers.
It has some of the most in-depth
Science content available anywhere:
covering space, technology, nature, and more
15 to 20 hours of new content is added
each week with a growing collection of 4K,
high-definition content for no additional cost,
so you will never run out of something
to watch, and there are no ads.
MagellanTV can be watched anytime, anywhere,
on your television, laptop, or mobile device
because it’s compatible with Roku,
AmazonFireTV, AppleTV, Google Play, and iOS
Click on the link in the description to get
your first full month of MagellanTV for free.
All the peoples names you see on the screen
right now, they are the people who support us
on Patreon. They give us a little money, so that
we can continue making this show, because look,
we understand that we are extremely excited
about magnetotaxis, but many people aren’t, and
that’s okay. It’s a big diverse world. But with
tools like Patreon, and great people like these,
amazing content about amazing bacteria, can still
survive on YouTube. So thanks to much to all of
them, and if you want to join them, you can go to
Patreon.com/JounreyToMicro. If you’d like to see
more from our Master of Microscopes James Weiss,
make sure to check out Jam & Germs on Instagram,
and if you’d like to see more from us, there’s
probably a Subscribe button somewhere nearby.